we'd like to think audible for
supporting PBS how we access music is
always evolving from vinyl records to
cassette tapes to streaming but a
streaming service like Spotify isn't
just changing how we access music it's
actually changing the music itself
Spotify has been up ending the music
industry for a solid decade 100 million
subscribers have some 35 million songs
at their fingertips for ten dollars a
month this new business model has
completely changed the way musicians
make money as New York Times music
critic Jon Caramanica put it I think
it's probably easier than ever to make a
little bit of money I think it's harder
than ever to make a lot of money but the
change isn't only economic bands now
need to vie for a coveted spot on one of
Spotify his curated playlists to reach
the millions of listeners who tune into
these playlists every week when I saw
the Spotify influence your music
I think we'd love to say it doesn't but
at least I think it's in my head
probably and it's a weird thing to kind
of think about like you know there's
this trick of sliding choruses up to the
beginning of songs just to catch
somebody on a playlist because a lot of
those listeners are just passive
listeners they're not your followers
you're competing with so much noise per
week so you've got to do something kind
of grabs people right upfront this
competition is actually pushing some
artists to change how they write songs
in order to optimize their music for
Spotify that might sound like the music
world is selling out but is it really
anything new not really
format has always changed the way
artists to make music in the early 20th
century the poor sound quality of the
phonograph influenced some early jazz
bands to replace their double bass with
a tuba so listeners could actually hear
the instrument
in the 1920s Russian composer Igor
Stravinsky composed each of the four
movements in his serenade and eight to
be three minutes long so pitch could fit
on one side of the 78 rpm record soon
losing country musicians found
themselves trimming down songs to fit on
records too it's a trend that would
extend for decades well into the FM
radio era mark Katz author of capturing
sound how technology has changed music
told Smithsonian magazine the
three-minute pop song is basically an
invention of the phonograph
so Spotify is just a new phonograph to
understand how Spotify is changing music
you have to follow the money
Spotify pays copyright holders about
point zero six two point zero eight four
dollars per stream but only if the
listener streams the song for at least
30 seconds they don't stick around for
at least 30 seconds the artists don't we
pay this has created a few key
incentives for artists one is to put
more songs on each album more songs
means more opportunities to make money
and you can see this in recent albums
like migos culture 2 and drake's
scorpion each of which pack a couple
dozen songs more songs could also help
an album go gold in 2016 the Recording
Industry Association of America started
factoring streams into their method for
certifying gold and platinum albums so
with more songs problem artists can
increase their chances of getting more
streams and possibly see their album go
go but while albums might be getting
longer pop songs are actually getting
shorter in 2013 the average song on the
Billboard 100 was 3 minutes and 50
seconds according to a recent report
from quartz in 2018 that averaged up to
3 minutes and 30 seconds what does that
have to do with Spotify the answer could
be related to Spotify his 30-second role
because the platform pays out when a
stream lasts 30 seconds there's little
financial incentive to write super long
songs there is however an incentive to
hook listeners quickly gone are the days
of elaborate intros now you're more
likely to hear artists front-load a song
with courses or go for broke in the
first few seconds of a song like in Katy
Perry's swish-swish which opens with a
familiar sample from Fat Boy slim
which work work is work in 2017
singer-songwriter Emily Warren told
pitchfork
that session musicians have genuinely
been saying oh we need to make something
that sounds like Spotify so what is the
Spotify sound leaned on by Major Lazer &
DJ snake featuring moe is a pretty good
example with more than 1 billion
listeners on Spotify the 2015 hit was
once the platform's most streamed song
but what made it so optimized for
streaming for one the song opens with a
catchy syncopated statement of the main
chords before quickly getting to Moe's
vocals the rest of lean on contains
elements you're likely to find in many
successful songs on Spotify it's got a
danceable four-on-the-floor beast it's
got a simple and catchy chorus
it's under three minutes long and it's
also clearly influenced by streaming
music first signature genre tropical
house which is a lighter take on the
deepest ranra trop house exploded in
popularity on Spotify around 2015
bringing tropical sounding synthesizers
and dancehall elements to mainstream
audience lean on also features one of
pop music's recently favorite
conventions the pop drop which is
essentially a toned down version of an
EDM bass drop lean on is an expertly
crafted pop song that's broadly
appealing and familiar those are good
qualities to have if your goal is to
succeed on Spotify after all studies
have shown that people prefer music that
they're familiar with and streaming data
indicates that people tend not to skip
songs that they've heard before many
listeners today engage in what digital
marketers have dubbed
lean back listen this term describes
Spotify listeners who prefer to select
the playlist and let it roll rather than
selecting songs individually music that
is familiar and accessible is more
likely to blend in with the playlist and
avoid getting skipped off set of migos
said he's obsessed with industry data
and uses it to modify how he approaches
writing music but does tailoring your
art for the aggregate preferences of a
streaming service make songwriting any
less creative Grammy Award winner Sarah
McLachlan seems to think so
she told the CBC if people are writing
music from that particular format and I
find that sad and she would know sad
check out our sad song episode but could
the opposite be true is it possible that
Spotify the incentives are merely
tweaking what's always been a heavily
commercialized art form I happen to like
pop music
he likes pop music so we make probably
together somewhat accessible music that
has a home on some of these platforms
you know I think you kind of have to
write good songs but I don't think you
can think like too heavily on this is
gonna work great on Spotify is there a
Spotify sound in your opinion I
wholeheartedly I mean there's and then
for a while there was mumble rap I think
that song a Spotify song is
ever-changing probably you know from
season to season Ellie and I are going
to write a song with all of the elements
Spotify loves
hopefully it ends up with a billion
streams well what do you think about
Spotify I think it definitely has
changed how music is made how we listen
to music
I think we should play with in the song
that we create is the length of it the
length of the song I think it should be
a 30-second song a 30-second typical
typical song feels fashioned maybe we
should be appealing to Gen Z and they're
streaming natives we are streaming
immigrants I'm saying like we grew up
with other things before we hear our
Spotify style track we like to thank
audible for supporting PBS audible
selection of audiobooks includes audible
originals audio titles created by
storytellers from around the literary
world
for example pitch inaudible original
series that illustrates why music is so
central in our connections to each other
our history and culture visit
audible.com slash sound field or text
sound field to 500 500 to learn more
members own their books and can access
them anytime to learn more visit
audible.com slash Southfield or tech
soundfield to 500 500 Lindsey is like
streaming natives but they're immigrants
to opening a CD and peeling the sticker
off and we're looking at the liner notes
and seeing the poster in there they
don't know them about that well I think
we talk